[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour le
78 politique nouveau rendez-vous sur
TVfil la parenthèse des élections
municipales aujourd'hui refermé je
recevrai tous les 15 jours sur ce
plateau des élus mais aussi des
militants pour commenter l'actualité
politique du moment premier invité en ce
8 avril Philippe Chevrier bonsoir
bonsoir le responsable départemental du
Front national on va forcément revenir
sur vos résultats au derniè municipal
mais aussi évoquer les européennes qui
se profilent ce sera à la fin du mois de
mai tout d'abord les municipales 41
conseillers municipaux 11 conseillers
communautaires dans le département des
ivelines c'est le bilan comptable est-ce
que cela répond à vos objectifs ah bah
c'est très très au-dessus bien entendu
alors évidemment c'est beaucoup à cause
du résultat de manentelaville qui a
évidemment grossi le nombre de
conseillers M la ville ou Ciril not le
candidat a été élu et prend la tête de
la ville c'est VO seule ville frond
nationale dans l'Î de franceance voilà
voilà il nous apporte une vingtaine de
conseillers municipaux donc du coup
effectivement bon ça gonfle les
résultats mais de toute façon même si on
ne prend pas mantelaville
en en cause en compte
pardon les résultats sont très très
au-dessus de de de ce qu'on pouvait
espérer déjà déjà on a eu l'occasion
d'en parler ici le nombre de listes
qu'on a pu présenter m'a moi-même étonné
puisque je souhaite éta au départ n'en
présenta qu'une à Versailles bon donc
évidemment tout tout s'est enclenché et
tout a été une a fait une espèce de
d'effet boule de neige qui fait que bah
maintenant effectivement on a on a ce
résultat qui est qui est très très
au-dessus de ce qu'on pouvait espérer
alors déjà quand quand on s'était
vu c'était juste avant le premier tour
quand on présentait 16 listes qu'on
avait 750 colistiers
euh l'objectif c'était d'en avoir 15
voilà bon bon alors même si on retire la
vingtaine de de mantelaville on est déjà
très au-dessus de de ce qu'on de ce
qu'on espérait au meilleur de nos de de
nos espérances quoi on va revenir sur
mant laaville cette seule victoire
véritablement du Front national en
île-de-franceche mais déjà sur les élus
qui vont siéger dans l'opposition quel
rôle pour eux qu'est-ce que vous
attendez d'eux d'Alexander nicolic à
plaisir par exemple de Nicolas Boer à
elencour ou encore de François Siméoni à
versaill ou de vous-même à Rambouillet
également quel sera le rôle quelle place
pour ses élus Front national alors ça
c'est d'abord d'être le regard des des
habitants de ces villes euh dans ce qui
se passe au dans le conseil municipal ça
c'est très important alors regard à quel
point de vue d'abord sur les finances
très clair les dépenses les dépenses
regarder de très près les dépenses en
particulier euh les dépenses
samptuaires donc en faire en faire euh
état bon éventuellement dire évidemment
nos nos positions à l'intérriur du
conseil municipal mais surtout alerter
les gens alerter les les les populations
sur ce qui se passe bon regardez aussi
euh les dépenses de fonctionnement
est-ce que à chaque fois que quelqu'un
qu'un fonctionnaire part en retraite
est-ce qu'il y a nécessité de le
remplacer est-ce qu'on pourrait pas euh
agir sur un peu de mobilité à
l'intérieur même des effectifs euh des
communes en question voilà le but c'est
pas de baisser les dépenses pour le
plaisir de baisser les dépenses c'est de
baisser les impôts voilà ça qu'on
cherche à faire parce que franchement on
pense que à la fois au plan national et
au plan local les impôts sont beaucoup
trop élevés aujourd'hui et mais dans
certaines communes vous n'avez qu'un
seul élu un seul élu dans l'opposition
c'est suffisant pour pour peser pour se
faire entendre pour peser pour se faire
entendre certes parce qu'on peut
toujours se faire entendre peser ça je
dirais c'est la responsabilité de
l'exécutif de dire si de de de nous
suivre ou pas hein parce qu'il y a pas
eu d'alliance même avec d'autres groupes
de d'opposition si ce'est sur Versailles
il y a eu des rapprochements avec
certaines tendances politique on peut
toujours se rapprocher effectivement
avec les uns avec les autreselon en
fonction don de de des sensibilités mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas le but hein le
but c'est effectivement de s'exprimer
après charge à l'exécutif de prendre en
compte ou pas et et surtout d'informer
les gens de de de ce qui se passe et de
bien regarder ce qui se passe voilà les
Scor municipales dans toutes les
communes si on regarde un petit peu dans
dans le détail ce n'est pas toujours les
mêmes el encour 7,48 % Versailles 10,1
chaque score forcément à son exp c'est
un scrutin local mais globalement on
peut avoir le sentiment que le Fond
national s'impose moins dans le
département des eveling qu'au niveau
national les chiffres sont finalement
moins bon écoutez j'ai pas
comparé franchement j'ai pas comparé
d'une manière générale d'une manière
générale le front les scores du Front
national dans les Yvelines sont plutôt
moins bons que les scores du Front
National au niveau national donc c'est
pas une
surprise votre propre score je vous
interromp mais grandouillet vous faites
un petit peu moins bien sur le deuxème
tour que premier et c'est à peu près le
résultat que vous aviez fait lors des
élections législatives on est autour de
10 % c'est pas une déception vous n'avez
pas pu capitaliser ou progresser
pourquoi dans le département des ieline
le Front national finalement progresse
moins dans le reste de la France non
alors attendez j'étais en train de
répondre mais là il s'est passé entre
les deux tours quelque chose d'autre
alors il y a d'abord le résultat le
résultat en lui-même bon je regardais la
moyenne de ce qu'on a fait au premier
tour par rapport à la moyenne de ce
qu'on a fait au législativ bon c'est pas
des moyennes pondérées mais comme je ne
l'ai pas fait ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre ça se compare quand même pas mal
euh on a augmenté de de près d'un point
par rapport au législatif or je rappelle
quand même que cette élection ne nous
est pas favorable parce que on n pas de
sortant donc en général c'est quand même
favorable au sortant si leur bilan est
correct évidemment mais en général bon
c'est le cas et bon malgré tout on a
quand même progressé donc c'est plutôt
encourageant alors maintenant qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé entre les deux tours
effectivement euh et pas seulement Caren
Bouillet même je dirais à Rouillen on a
plutôt bien
résisté il y a mais dans quatre communes
on a régressé assez fortement on est
passé je dirais je généralise un peu
mais on est passé de la bande des 20 % à
plutôt la bande des 10 % donc on a
divisé par 2 donc ce qui s'est passé
c'est que les gens on ont comment dire
se sont orientés vers un vote utile euh
de gauche droite quoi c'est ça c'était
ça essentiellement qui qui qui était en
jeu donc ça revient à dire qu'au premier
tour c'était un vote de contestation
contre les partis UMP et PS formation
traditionnelle ancrée droite gauche et
qu'au 2ième tour vous n'avez pas pu
miser sur un vote d'adhésion pas pas
nécessairement de contestation je pense
que c'était déjà un vote d'adhésion au
premier tour mais ce qui se passe c'est
qu' à un moment donné vous regard les
les les gens regardent le résultat du
premier tour et puis bon ils voient les
forces en présence donc il voi qui peut
gagner qui peut gêner le gagnant et
cetera et à ce moment-là les équipes se
mettent en en branle et du coup les les
les les
les scores inférieurs pâtissent il y a
pas que le Front National qui a pâti de
ça entre les deux tours bon voilà c'est
ce qui s'est passé bon c'est un peu
dommage dans dans certaines communes
mais bon voilà c'est la règle du jeu
faut s'y faire la droite en tout cas
l'UMP l'UDI progresse dans le
département des ivelines' il n'y a plus
que 18 communes à gauche sur 262
aujourd'hui dans le département c'est
parce que beaucoup ont basculé du PS
vers l'UMP et ses alliés on revient sur
cette vague bleue avec ce
reportage une vague bleue sans précédent
dans les ivelines déjà largement ancré à
droite le département est quasiment sous
le contrôle de l'UMP et de son allié
l'UDI sous l'impulsion nationale de
nombreux bastions socialistes dans les
Yvelines Tom à l'issue de ces
municipales DEP pas à boisarc en passant
par Conflant saint-onorine où le
président de Région Jean-Paul Huchon a
été notamment maire ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous avons choisi les bons
candidats pour cette élection qui
avaient des bonnes équipes et des bons
projet et j'ajoute aussi que dans les
ivelines il y a un label de qualité de
gestion des villes de droite par des
maires de droite des bastions
communistes aussi passent à droite dont
à cher mais la victoire la plus
emblématique pour l'UMP reste celle de
la communauté d'agglomération de 5 en
iveline en plus la cas qui qui est le le
vraiment le le le système de de
développement un des gros un des gros
bastions de de de dévelop pour
développer l'économie et l'emploi qui
est quand même la première attente
défaner on est très content bien sûr de
je dirais de pouvoir reprendre en main
la responsabilité des élus sera de
continuer cette réussite quels que
soient les élus quels que soient les
élus quel que soit la direction notre
responsabilité devant devant les
habitants devant les entreprises devant
nos enfants c'est de continuer cette
réussite et vous pouvez compter sur moi
pour passer la main dans ces conditions
là parce que l'œuvre qui a été accompli
pour moi ce qui est le plus important
c'est qu'elle continue la gauche ne
détient plus qu'une poignée de commune
dans les ivelines dont quatre qui
composent l'agglomération de sa-quenttin
je suis très satisfaite de voir que dans
un contexte national que nous vivons
pour le Parti socialiste un contexte de
défaite hein on a réussi sur
l'agglomération de de SaintQuentin à
conserver des villes à gauche et avec
des scorses qui sont quand même assez
assez bons largement majoritaire aux
élections ces dernières années le PS
pourrait connaître une série de défaites
le 25 mai ce seront les élections
européennes en septembre les
sénatoriales et l'année prochaine en
2015 les
régionales retour sur le plateau du 78
politique nouveau rendez-vous sur TV fil
dans la prolongation des élections
municipales je reçois donc Philippe
Chevrier on revient avec vous sur les
résultats du Front national dans le
département nous évoquions le rôle des
élus d'opposition de ce que vous
attendiez de dans les conseils
municipaux je vous propose d'écouter la
déclaration de Michel logier le maire de
Montini le Bretonneux le prochain
président a priori de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline il réagissait
sur ce plateau à l'arrivée d'un
représentant du Front national dans son
opposition à
Montini je suis un démocrate ce que je
comprends pas forcément ce sont les
électeurs qui vont vers cette formation
politique vous savez il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui anticipent les choses
elles ont tellement peur que elles vont
vers vers vers autre chose c'est un peu
comme vous savez les personnes sont
souvent plus vulnérabl avant de souffrir
que lorsqu'elle souffr hein il y en a
qui sont déjà dans dans dans des
conditions psychologiques différentes de
peur de souffrir alors que lorsqu'on
souffre on résiste beaucoup plus donc
voilà donc je crois que cette
anticipation était mal venue parce que
je pense que sur montieni en ce qui
concerne les thèmes qui sont défendus
par cette formation politique nous
sommes largement au-delà de la de la
moyenne tout se passe plutôt bien en
tout cas aujourd'hui la démocratie a
donné un conseiller municipal Philippe
Chevrier qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
Michel logier c'est la peur qui explique
le vote Front national non en aucun cas
là en particulier surtout auprès d'un
maire qui nous explique que tout va bien
donc ça peut pas être la peur donc paré
d'un sentiment de peur qui devançait les
véritablés un sentiment de peur non je
crois que il n'arrive pas à comprendre
lui comme d'ailleurs les les maires de
gauche que les gens commencent à
comprendre que on les a floué pendant
des années en leur expliquant que l'euro
ça allait être le bonheur absolu que
l'Union européenne allait apporter de
l'emploi et cetera et qui se rendent
compte que bah c'est pas le cas que
voilà les les gouvernements les partis
de
gouvernement successif n'ont pas n'ont
pas réalisé leurs objectifs ni euh ni
leurs promesses et donc voilà ils se
tournent ils disent d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas maintenant essayer le Front national
on l'entend souvent maintenant euh parce
que ils ont compris que le Front
national avait un programme un programme
cohérent il y en a certains qui vont
voir même par milliers qui vont voir qui
vont consulter le programme du Front
national sur le net je ne peux que
d'ailleurs les encourager pour qu'il voi
la cohérence du programme du du Front
National et je crois que petit à petit
ça progresse c'est-à-dire que maintenant
dans les mairies où vous êtes arrivés
aux affaires ce qui nous amène à
montelaville notamment il va falloir se
montrer aussi à la hauteur et proposer
quelque chose de différent absolument
mais tout tous nos candidat parce qu'il
y a des précédents lors des des
anciennes échéances municipal le Front
National est déjà arrivé en
responsabilité dans certaines communes
notamment dans le sud de la France et ça
s'est pas toujours très bien passé bah
écoutez ça s'est bien passé au niveau
des finances en tout cas hein parce que
ils ont laissé les mairies dans un état
financier bien meilleur que celui dans
lequel ils l'ont trouvé puis après ça a
dérapé ça a dérapé je le rappelle quand
ces gens-là d'ailleurs sont passés à
l'UMP donc c'est pas tout à fait la
faute du Front national donc je me
permet de dire ça
maintenant les objectifs sont ambitieux
hein pour le Front national aujourd'hui
dans les ivelines c'est pas tout je veux
dire il va falloir effectivement
travailler à Mont laaville il va falloir
faire quelque chose de bien mais nous
avons un programme un programme cohérent
un programme municipal qui est cohérent
dans toutes les municipalités alors je
vous disais d'entrée de jeu baisser les
dépenses baisser les impôts et ça
d'année en année régulièrement pendant
tout le mandat ça on s'y engage bon ça
c'est quelque chose que les gens vont
apprécier maintenant il il y a d'autres
choses qui sont spécifiques à chaque
ville je pense que vous allez inviter
Cyril not il va vous expliquer ce qui
veut faire pour spécifiquement sur Man
mais peut-être justement si on
s'intéresse à Man cyil n donc qui a été
élu c'est une surprise finalement cette
victoire parce que ce qui a profiter
pour le Fond national c'est aussi la
division il y avait beaucoup de listes à
droite comme à gauche le Fond national
s'impose mais la majorité finalement
assez assez courte elle est très courte
elle est absolument très courte non je
crois que d'ailleurs juste pour être
complet sur ça et pour pour rebondir
juste sur cette élection un recours a
été déposé he par le numéro 2 de la
liste PS Europe Écologie qui parle de
signature suspecte donc il y a un
recours qui sera instruit par la suite
c'est curieux d'ailleurs parce que comme
c'était eu c'est pas le seul recours
dans le département sur d'autres dans
d'autres communes aussi et pas
uniquement sur le fond national c'est
c'est assez curieux parce que comme
c'était eux qui étaient en charge de
l'élection et des émergements maintenant
il ils considèrent que les émergements
se sont pas bien passés c'est un petit
peu qui quand même voilà non la majorité
est courte il va falloir faire très
attention être très sérieux et j'ai
toute confiance dans Cyril na pour mener
à bien cette tâche ça démarre
parfaitement bien il prend les très
bonnes décisions donc voilà je pour
l'instant je suis très satisfait il y a
eu quelques tension tout de même lors de
l'installation du conseil municipal
c'était vendredi dernier il y a eu des
arrestations de manifestants en marge du
conseil municipal de ce premier conseil
municipal c'està-dire qu'il y a une
inquiétude dans cette ville bah vous
Saez surtout des excités d'extrême
gauche qui casse tout quoi donc dès que
les résultats sont pas ne sont pas
satisfaisants pour eux alors leur seul
mode d'expression c'est d'aller brûler
qu' pose la question aux habitants
savoir s'ils ont voté ou non pour pour
le Front national c'est pas forcément
spontanément que les gens disent oui
j'ai j'ailu j'ai voté pour cyil
not écoutez vous savez c'est ce qui
ressort dans la presse aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup d'articles sur ça est-ce
qu'on peut lire sur sur month sur la
commune demande c'est que les gens
acceptent forcément le résultat mais ne
revendiquent pas le vote en tout cas bah
écoutez pense non je pense pas je crois
que c'est c'est comme ça je veux dire le
le vote est un est secret hein par
définition donc je veux dire il est à
bulletin secret donc bon les gens ils
ont pas envie de de dire à la presse ce
qu'ils ont voté parce que bon imaginez
on vous demande est-ce que vous avez
voté Front national al admettons que
vous vous ayez voté Front national pas
trop envie de le dire ça regarde
personne vous n'avez pas voté votre
front national mais vous avez voté je
sais pas udi ou n'importe quoi bon euh
vous avez vous savez bien que si vous
dites non la deuxième question ce sera
mais pour qui avez-vous votter vous avez
pas envie de le dire non plus bon je
c'est assez normal que les gens soient
réticents à répondre à ces questions là
moi moi écoutez ça aurait été quand même
s'il y avait eu un tabou encore
maintenant ça aurait été très difficile
de faire les listes or apparemment
partout où on est allé on a réussi à
faire des listes facilement je donc non
franchement dans la popul il y a plus de
tabou maintenant dans les organes
politiques on ny est pas encore et dans
les et dans certains médias non plus
donc visiblement il y a encore des
tabous à ce niveau-là mais par contre
dans la population je crois que les gens
commencent à comprendre pour conclure
sur ces résultats au municipale sur la
question du rôle des élus aussi
qu'attendez-vous c'est la question que
nous sommes allés vous poser
qu'attendez-vous de ces élus Front
National qui soi dans l'opposition ou la
majorité vos réponse j'attends de voir
c'est facile de bien parler mais après
on verra sur les actes
peut-être certains qui apporteront
quelque chose mais pas tout le monde
quoi jusque là ils ont pas beaucoup
montré qu'ils avaient un programme on
verra bien Ren qui trouve un autre moyen
d'exprimer le nationalisme et le
patriotisme que celui qui est promu par
leur parti faut voir ce qu'ils vont
faire et puis après on pourra dire si
c'est bien ou pas bien d'un point de vue
personnel je pense que ce qu'il font ce
qu'ils veulent faire c'est pas approprié
à la demande vraiment des gens qui sont
dans la ville quoi faut voir
pour savoir ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire et ne pas les mettre déjà au
pilori avant d'avoir entendu et vu ce
qu'il pouvait faire franchement
honnêtement j'attends rien du tout de ce
parti là maintenant il y a beaucoup de
gens qui se cachent derrière derrière ça
parce qu'il y a tellement de choses qui
vont pas que les gens ils veulent des
solutions c'est pour ça que maintenant
on voit énormément de mixité dans le
Front
national c'est quelques réactions
recueillies notamment h encour ou Nicola
Boer donc pour le Fond national a fait
son entrée au conseil municipal si vous
souhaitez réagir à ce micro trottoir
sinon on va ensuite parler des
on entendu les gens attendent de voir
maintenant mais ça ça relie la question
que vous posiez tout à l'heure c'est que
il y a quand même la grande victoire
aujourd'hui c'est quand même
l'abstention h hein et ça c'est quand
même un signe évident que les gens se
méfient maintenant de la politique ils
pensent que les politiciens ne peuvent
plus leur apporter de choses concrètes
on entendait là on va les juger sur des
choses
concrètes ils ne se laissent plus
prendre au langage quoi ils ne se
laissent plus prendre à ça ils attendent
de voir bon il y en a beaucoup qui sont
restés c'est chez eux parce que
justement voilà ils se méfient et puis
euh ils vont ils vont être à mon avis
ils vont être très vigilant sur les les
résultats de des des politiques cette
fois-ci dans leur communes et c'est bien
c'est bien c'est ce qu'il faut un
scrutin qui peinene toujours à mobiliser
encore plus que pour les élections
municipales ce sont les européennes les
européennes forcément le Front national
faisait des municipales un tremplin pour
les élections européennes il y aura des
candidats dans toutes les les régions
pour l'î- de France la liste est déjà
arrêtée aussi comment se passe la
composition de la liste écoutez c'est
possible qu'elle soit arrêtée notre tête
de liste en tout cas c'est Monsieur
emmeric choprade euh qui était un
géopoliticien très connu et bon pour
l'instant l'intégralité de la liste
n'est pas connue en tout cas moi je ne
la connais pas donc on verra normalement
elle devrait sortir vous serez a priori
en tout cas vous souhaiteriez être sur
cette liste j'espère les organisation de
jeunesse des quatre partis européens
d'extrême droite ont annoncé vendredi
leur intention de lancer des actions
communes dans la la campagne en vu de
ces élections européennes est-ce que ce
sera le cas également pour pour leurs
aînés pour le Front national est-ce que
vous allez vous allier avec les autres
formations à travers l'Europe pour faire
campagne ou est-ce que le Front national
partira seul écoutez à ma connaissance
on part seul euh voilà on part seul on
parle sur le on part sur le territoire
français et on parle des problèmes des
Français par rapport à l'Europe il y
aura une volonté d'intégrer un groupe
une fois une fois des élus en place
c'est déjà fait c'est déjà fait hein
Marine Le Pen de même que son père avait
en son temps avait en son temps qui
siège déjà avait en son temps créé ou ou
participer à des à des groupements avec
Bruno golnich qui était d'ailleurs
président de l'un d'eux euh voilà bon
Marine Le Pen d'ailleurs a un peu
réorienté tout ça
bon voilà une fois que le groupe sera
installé au Parlement ils verront avec
qui ils pourront s'allier en fonction
des résultats des élections des autres
aussi hein donc ça c'est un peu trop tôt
dans le cadre des élections de faire de
faire alliance comme ça donc bon on a
des problèmes spécifiques à la France on
les traite un sondage le dernier sondage
hipsos fin mars l'UMP 24 % en tête des
intentions de vote pour les élections
européennes du 25 mai devant le Front
national 22 % et le PS 19 % vous pensez
tenir la la cadence d'ici le 25 mai ah
est-ce que l'objectif c'est même de
passer devant l'UMP ah c'est l'objectif
absolument de passer devant l'UMP bien
sûr bien sûr mais d'ailleurs dans les
ivelines je enfin je veux dire les
résultats sont encourageants
bon bon je vous disais on doit être
autour de 13 voilà sur les municipales
bon où on s'est présenté je pense que
dans les petits villages et cetera
l'entour notamment dans la 9e et la 8e
circonscription des Yvelines on devrait
faire des scores bien meilleurs j'en
veux pour preuve de certaines
cantonnales où on avait fini au 2ème
tour à à près de 40 % donc on a on a des
des bons réservoirs de voix par rapport
au municipal si on se projette sur les
européennes donc je pense que si on fait
un calcul raisonnable on devrait être à
15 aujourd'hui sur le dans les Yvelines
euh au Nive si si on se si on faisait
une élection aujourd'hui européenne on
serait à peu près à 15 bon je pense
qu'il va y avoir un débat il va y avoir
un débat enfin sur l'Europe enfin sur
l'euro enfin on va pouvoir s'exprimer
sur ces sujetslà enfin on va pouvoir
convaincre les gens que voilà c'est un
éche c'est la volonté du FR nation
absolent il faut sortir de l'euro c'est
un c'est un must si on veut décoller si
si on veut s'enfermer on peut y rester
mais si on veut décoller c'est c'est la
c'est le seul je dis pas que c'est c'est
c'est c'est la solution à tous les
problèmes mais c'est la base même sur
laquelle on peut construire quelque
chose sinon on pourra rien faire voilà
donc ce débat va avoir lieu on dit 22 au
niveau national on est un petit peu en
retrait je vous le disais 20 l'objectif
pour moi dans les yelines c'est 20 %
c'est 20 % le soir des élections
européennes pour les c'est un objectif
ambitieux mais je crois qu'on peut
l'atteindre et Emeric choprat qui sera
donc le candidat en Îlede-France donc
forcément aussi pour les yvelin est-ce
que c'est un bon candidat je vous pose
cette question parce que par le passé il
a aussi fait polémique on va tout de
même le présenter proche de Philippe
Devillier 45 ans docteur en sciences
politiques Sorbonne diplômé en
communication ressources humaines
sciences pour Paris euh il a répété
aussi plusieurs fois qu'il avait des
doute sur la version officielle des
attentats du 11 septembre est-ce que
c'est un bon candidat est-ce que c'est
un bon porte-parole pour le frond
national on va pas juger quelqu'un à sa
version c'est des des des événements du
11 septembre c'est un excellent
géopoliticien en ce qui concerne tout ce
qui tout ce qui se passe en Europe par
rapport à la Russie et cetera
l'Allemagne et et les forces en présence
c'est un excellent analyste il est
reconnu comme tel il donne des cours un
peu partout je crois que non c'est un
excellent c'est un excellent candidat
avec lequel en tout cas moi
personnellement je suis totalement en
phase surt ce que j'ai entendu de lui
jusqu'à présent et je vais pas m'arrêter
aux histoires du 11 septembre
franchement c'est c'est anecdotique quoi
ça permet tout de même de de resituer de
redonner des informations sur sur la
personne pour qui on est amené à voter
lors du scrutin il y a beaucoup de
scrutins à suivre dans les prochaines
années on parlait des européennes mais
il y a aussi les cantonnales les
sénatoriales est-ce que ce sont des des
scrutins que le Front national attend
aussi ou est-ce que déjà vous vous
projetez sur les présidentielles avec
Marine Le Pen alors les les cantonales
bien sûr comme comme à chaque fois on va
être très présent sur les cantonnales
ces résultats deurs locaux nous nous
bien sûr nous encouragent en ce qui
concerne les sénatorial bon on y sera
aussi on y était d'ailleurs la dernière
fois on y sera ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile hein puisque on n pas
suffisamment de d'élus pour prétendre
éventuellement avoir un poste dans les
ivines encore que nous verrons bien mais
on ira quand même et avec conviction et
on fera campagne au sénatorial j'aurai
une dernière question à vous poser c'est
sur les communes où le Front national
n'apparaissait pas sur ces municipales
vous allez nous dire si oui ou non se
développer dans le département et dans
certaines communes fait partie de vos
priorité pour l'instant nous revenons
sur l'installation de de plusieurs
d'entre eux tout d'abord nous partons
pour morpa p qui a donc basculé à droite
Grégory garestier pour l'UMP a pris la
tête de la commune pour les 6 prochaines
années à 32
ans de l'émotion chez Grégory garestier
et lu maire de morpa à l'issue d'une
triangulaire au cours de laquelle trois
anciens adjoints de la majorité sortant
céta é allié une alliance difficile
entre trois tendances politiques qui
aujourd'hui se retrouve dans
l'opposition le charme de la République
c'est de féliciter ceux qui ont gagné
donc je félicite ceux qui ont gagné ça
ne veut pas dire que celui qui félicite
n'aurait pas envie de voir autre chose
se réaliser mais la vie politique c'est
un très très long parcours Michel chaapa
adoubé par le maire sortant George
moujot et tête de liste était absent
lors du premier conseil municipal il
devrait être de retour lors de la
prochaine séance et il y a du travail
sur la planche dès lundi je vais réunir
les directeurs de service pour faire un
point sur les dossiers et engager en
tout cas les priorités qui sont celles
de mon projet pour les morpasiens mon
élection également c'est la victoire de
la sincérité de l'intégrité et de
l'enfant de morpas que je suis et donc
mes racines sont donc profondes et je
vais vraiment tout donner pendant 6 ans
pour améliorer le quotidien des
morpasiens et être à l'écoute pendant
toutes ces années Grégory garestier qui
sous les yeux de Valérie PCR s'est
défendu de vouloir mener une chasse aux
sorcières dans les services et qui a
salué le travail des équipes
de installation donc au conseil
municipal de morpa morpa il y avait
beaucoup de listes mais il n'y avait pas
de liste Fond national est-ce que cette
commune comme d'autres d'ailleurs font
partie de des priorités pour l'avenir
est-ce que vous souhaitez vous implter
plus bien sûr et si on ne l' pas c'est
unque de ma faute puisque j'avais prévu
au départ de faire une liste à
Versailles et que je n'imaginais pas que
ce serait aussi pas facile mais faisable
de faire des listes maintenant que je le
sais maintenant que je l'ai vérifié et
avec mes amis donc c'est sûr que au
prochaines municipal on aura un maximum
de candidats partout notamment à MPa ou
Vincent ça sera l'objectif de Vincent
Texier qui est le nouveau secrétaire de
il sera candidat à la mairie de MPa je
vous le dis d'ici 6 ans nous aurons bien
évidemment att d'y revenir merci
Philippe Chevrier responsable
départemental du Fond national on se
retrouve pour un prochain numéro de 78
politique il sera question des
européennes avec le scrutin qui se
déroule le 25 mai et toujours cet enjeu
lutter contre l'abstention très bonne
semaine merci à
[Musique]
vous